if the average person turns on the TV
and wants to know more about what's
going on with Ukraine and Russia they
would probably say zelinski is a hero
they would consider him Churchill
uh Putin is the next Hitler
they would say Putin is sick he's weak
Ukraine is beating and winning the war
America is doing a great job given all
this support to Ukraine and getting
involved uh it's it's a great job we're
doing taking care of these guys
everybody wants to go have a meeting
with zelinski just a couple days ago
Jill Biden was in Ukraine having a
private meeting with zielinski's wife
first lady
and Trudeau was just there from Canada
spending some time with zelinski it is
it has become in a and the world is
getting behind zelinski now as a person
that's extremely paranoid and let's add
a new word to my vocabulary suspicious
right I'm sitting there now wondering is
there something I don't know that was
one of the reasons why we wanted to
bring you here because I want to see
maybe you got a different perspective
that we don't see
when you see what the news is saying
when you see what's going on uh do you
see Putin getting weaker do you see him
sitting there or do you see saying he's
doing exactly what he was expecting
America to get into this to use this as
an excuse to create a war against U.S
and American people are not thinking the
negative side effects of what could
happen with this the next 3 6 12 24
months I don't know what is your
perspective how do you view what's going
on versus the rest of the world okay
well first I I do the think zelinski is
a church hill-like character because his
job is supposed to be to convince other
countries to come to the defense of
Ukraine even if it's not in their
interests I mean that's what Churchill
did with the United States in World War
II and that's what zielinski is doing
now he's supposed to be doing that so
that doesn't make him an evil person
Putin May well be Hitler okay but uh but
you have to but you have to uh Putin may
be well be Stalin all right but during
World War II we may made common cause
with Stalin against the guns the common
threat which was Nazi Germany and in my
view of the the West seems to have
completely forgotten to a strategic big
picture here and the big strategic big
picture is that we Face the free
countries uh face the greatest threat to
our security to our existence that we
have ever faced in the alliance that
exists between Russia and China and
their client states North Korea and Iran
in international terrorism all of whom
are part of a new block you know they
haven't formalized it with a treaty for
all of them although there are treaties
between Russia and China and the West
has been so slow to wake up to this
reality uh you know only now uh uh I bet
I've been saying for many years that
Russia and China are de facto allies and
it should seems to me it should have
been obvious to anyone you know who had
been following the history of the
relations between Russia and China
China's superpower cape abilities are
built on Russian technology you know uh
the uh their their new missiles uh you
know their their Advanced aircraft their
ships and everything uh you know Russia
basically helped build China into the
great military uh threat that it is
today it's likewise with North Korea you
know uh has it's amazing to me that
Washington never seemed to be
as surprised as it should be that North
Korea you know could go so rapidly uh to
acquire Atomic weapons than the hydrogen
bomb last December the displays the uh
the world's largest mobile ICBM uh that
people think is going to call it carry
mervs now which is called multiple
independently targeted Rancher Vehicles
so one missile can send many independent
how could North Korea do that all by
itself well it hasn't done it all by
itself it's missile technology has been
provided to it by Russia and China they
want North Korea to pull them to become
a nuclear threat to the United States so
they can fight a proxy nuclear war
against us if they have to uh to uh
drive us out of the Pacific by raising
the risks of providing our alliance
guarantees to our allies in the Pacific
uh uh you know so that we to change our
strategic calculus to say well you know
if we defend South Korea we might get in
a nuclear war with North Korea is it
worth the candle if we defend Japan is
it worth example to risk Los Angeles and
a nuclear war with North Korea likewise
with Iran into the Iranian nuclear
program the the uh those are Russian
nuclear reactors that were built for
them the Russians are building more
nuclear reactors the North Koreans
missiles are based on usually based on
North Korean technology their best
medium-range missile the shahab three is
really a souped-up version of North
Korea's nodong and there are North
Korean scientists and technicians and
Russian and Chinese scientists and
technicians in Iran helping them develop
their nuclear missile programs so they
have been a clandestine block okay now
finally Washington has seized that all
Russia and China really are allies
they've been hoping that that hasn't
been true for for many years right up
until the Ukrainian crisis but they are
alive and our
job number one for us you know is is to
be prepared to defeat this block this
totalitarian power block uh that is
coming you know they are a bigger threat
to us by far than Nazi German and the
Imperial Japan were in World War II you
know because they can destroy our
homeland now did you just say they're a
bigger threat oh yeah the Nazi in
Germany was in World War the Nazi
Germany and Imperial Japan combined in
fascist Italy combined because the the
those the totalitarian powers of that
day could not reach across the oceans
they couldn't project power across the
ocean now they can and they could
destroy our society in 30 minutes and
all their even even their allies and we
should by the way when a country gets
nuclear missiles you really need to
think of them as a superpower you know
we like to think of superpowers as you
know meeting an economic definition when
it comes to life and death what matters
is because that country destroy you and
can they do it quickly North Korea could
destroy us and it could do it quickly
that makes them a superpower even though
the rest of their economy in no other
respect are they a superpower but it
doesn't matter when it comes to life and
death they are a superpower in Iran I
believe is already a superpower I think
that we've it's another topic I just
published a
uh
a report today as a matter of fact it
was uh you know carried in uh in Israel
called Iran EMP threat where I make the
case that Iran has already got nuclear
weapons that they've had them for some
time I'm not the only one who believes
that you know there's a uh uh you know a
very credible minority view in the
American strategic community that never
gets heard okay that says hey Iran has
already got the bomb but this is the
most formidable combination we've ever
faced in our history and I don't think
we can beat it you know if we have to
end up having a protracted new Cold War
against this combination we're going to
lose and if it goes into a hot War we're
going to lose even worse so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]